as far as we can tell a breakup isn't
phasing arena shake one bit
arena appeared to be in good spirits on
Thursday the model was spotted arriving
at the Los Angeles International Airport
the pic was snapped just hours before
news officially broke that she and
longtime partner Bradley Cooper were
splitting up after four years together a
source tells ET quote recently arena
decided enough is enough she didn't feel
she was getting the level of commitment
she wanted and the endless fighting made
their life unbearable now back to that
Airport sighting that's the 33 year olds
rocking a tan jumpsuit black shades and
matching shoes smiling ear-to-ear while
chatting with someone on her phone and
while arena looked chic as hell
there was one accessory that was
noticeably missing the emerald ring that
she usually sports on that finger it was
the bling that she started wearing in
2016 that had lots of fans speculating
that she and Bradley were engaged before
her airport a rival arena stopped by a
nail salon for some pampering wearing an
all-black look and again a killer smile
later she was seen leaving her house
with her suitcase and a coat in hand
getting in a limo the break up news
comes just months after romance rumors
with Lady gaga raged while the two
promoted a star is born
hey what I just want to take another
look at you a source tells et those
closest to them had high hopes that when
Bradley completed a star is born they
would find time to work out their
differences but things only got worse
quote they talked things through a great
deal and seemed to hold off and keep up
appearances for the time being it was
recommended they delay a split at what
seemed to be the peak of his career
because the negative attention would
take away from the excitement of the
release and house arena how's the family
they're all right
yes but ultimately Arina decided it was
time to call it quits and according to
multiple reports the pair is now working
on how to share custody of their
daughter Leah who they welcomed in 2017
family is everything
et has reached out to both reps for
Bradley an arena for comment of course
will be here to keep you up-to-date as
we learn more so make sure to keep it
locked on ET until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]